I am welcome to building an Internet
scale analytics platform on Google cloud
I am Shaquille Mayman I'm a customer
engineer with Google cloud along with me
I have Nikhil Mishra senior director of
engineering that Verizon media let's
give you an insight into today's
presentation in this session we'll be
present being complete end-to-end
solution architecture for building an
internet scale analytics platform on
Google cloud that over 100 plus
petabytes of data we will provide some
unique perspective and behind-the-scenes
thinking and some insight and how the
architecture has evolved in its current
form over the years we will talk about
how looker fits into the end-to-end
solution however aizen media is
generating actionable insights from the
wealth of data that they have and that
is coming along with the websites that
they have in place how they are
leveraging other Google Cloud offering
is like spanner pops up etcetera and how
this everything fits together in the
overall mix let's walk you through the
agenda so we will start with discussing
some of the challenges you face when
dealing with large scale and large
volumes of data we will discuss some of
the basic design principles when you get
started with the data analytics or data
warehousing project we will walk you
through one of the reference
architecture so give you some background
nikhil then we'll watch you through the
historical journey and how the
architecture has evolved from hadoo high
for tests and tableau to the current day
architecture with ado plus Google Cloud
Nikhil will also walk you through and
talk about the various Google cloud
offerings that are being used and what
they like about those offerings with
that let's take a look at the Verizon
media family of brands Verizon media
owns and operates more than a dozen
brand these are
some of the most visited and popular
properties and applications on the
Internet when you're talking about a
rich set of popular media brands like
young male young news a well Huffington
Post TechCrunch and gadget etc that are
visited by millions of users on a daily
basis you need a robust infrastructure
to support those users and meet their
expectations from a performance and
reliability perspective this gives you
some insight into what we are looking at
from numbers perspective these Pharisees
and media bands serve millions of users
who consume large volumes of data
reading or sending emails or browsing
through the content that is provided by
the web sites and applications which in
turn generate large volumes of data that
is being analyzed and utilized for
providing recommendations and serve as
the data analytics platform for the
corporate utilization now let's walk you
through a little bit deep now to give
you some further insight into what
Verizon media engineers are dealing with
on a daily basis there are a trillion
plus events generated which leads to
hundred plus terabytes of data now
Verizon media is always exploring based
on how best to serve that users interest
and meet their demands and obviously
their users expect fast and reliable
query performance and this is what they
have come to expect over the years their
users are spread all over the world and
we need to provide 7 by 24 support the
traffic being generated across the globe
with users around the world who are
accessing these websites and
applications from the laptops
smartphones and other devices like iPads
tablets and so many other things are out
there now let's take different aspect
and walk you through the big data
challenges now when you start out with
your data analytics project you will
identify the requirement
and you will pick and choose a few
commercially available products now in
in case of Verizon media when you're
dealing with this many number of users
and generating over a terabyte plus of
data not any infrastructure will work
now the next thing you do is like once
you have some things in place as far as
the design and requirements are
concerned is to pick and choose a
commercially available database in case
of Verizon media they cannot rely on
commercially available databases as most
of them failed to meet for as a media
requirements now from performance
perspective
whereas in media users have expected a
certain interactive response time which
has hard to maintain and sustain when
you're looking at this game with that
let me hand it over to Nick Hill and he
will walk you through some of the basic
design principles Thank You Shaquille
now let us take this forward and talk a
little bit more about how whereas in
media approves this problem and how we
were able to eventually solve it to take
us to the current architecture but we
have private cloud as well as Google
cloud into the mix to solve this problem
even if you are operating at a large
scale a massive scale and you attempted
to work around your technical
limitations or take shortcuts in order
to solve your problem we all know that
if you follow certain good time-tested
design principles you'd improve our
chances of success you can think of the
same theory for a DS applications and
the basic design principles for
analytics applications don't change with
scale they remain roughly the same for
an emetic systems you can think of think
of it as a collection of a fairly
decoupled or loosely coupled environment
of this components this different system
subsystems which take care of that
specific needs with different
architectural characteristics so you can
think of our DS environment as starting
off with a collection layer you
have a layer that is responsible
primarily for collecting data from
disparate data sources and making it
available for rest of your enterprise
for analytics this collection
environment would would be integrated
with and would be talking to a storage
layer that is responsible for primarily
collecting all this massive scale data
all in one place and making it available
for a rest of the ecosystem the storage
environment is not meant for direct ad
hoc access or interactive analytics in
order system the primary purpose of the
storage layer would be around reliable
storage efficient cost efficient storage
of pretty massive scale data retained
into failure
we don't want data to be lost at this
layer between collection and the store
in the single biggest priority
architectural priority if you want to
make a trade-off is reliability you
don't want any loss of data because data
once lost from one of these layers is
very hard to bring back this is loss
from the source and you don't want to be
in that situation
now once the data is available in the
storage layer you always need a
processing layer that is responsible for
reading data from this massive storage
layer and simplify it for further
analysis the primary goal of this layer
is to apply business logic build a set
of attributes and metrics which are
easily understood by your business and
allows them to query this environment
deep compute requirement in this layer
is slightly different from what you
would typically expect for a query
compute environment which will also form
one of the components of this system in
this processing layer the compute
requirement even though fairly elastic
is highly predictable you know what
volume of data you would typically get
over a big day or we can you can also
plan for the compute requirements for
specific time for events or special
holidays depending upon what your
business impacts are and you can plan
for those so the compute requirement
is limited to what you need and what
kind of business processing you Peter
this layer further makes available once
the data is ready it's made available in
a storage layer which is primarily the
store layer that your users are going to
use for interactive weighing of the data
the priority of this storage layer is
interactive ad hoc Nantes in this layer
you want to have characteristics that
helps you in a token Altec set scale you
want things like for example column the
storage you know that in data
warehousing environment users are not
going to vary all your data at once even
if your warehouse could be hundred
petabyte in size your queries would be
typically querying a few gigabytes or
few terabytes of data they won't be
querying entire hundred petabyte all the
time so you want to make sure that your
architect here storage architecture in
this layer supports those kind of ad hoc
access error analysis in a very
efficient manner you don't want to
overload your compute environment in the
query layer by wearing data that is not
needed by your queries at the top of the
pyramid you would have your analytics
compute the primary priority of this
compute environment is to make the data
from the anodic storage available for
your users in an interactive fashion
users can ask any queries they want any
questions they want the dishing people
to query this massive data warehouse
using this compute and be able to answer
the questions interactivity and
interactivity could mean a few seconds
it could also mean a few minutes if you
are doing a pretty complex and long
duration analysis the main goal of this
compute is around user response time and
those are very hard to predict you
cannot say that your business is going
to ask X number of questions on a given
day you cannot predict the user is going
to that this specific business process
is going to be more in demand in the
specific way it's very very hard to
predict what kind of compute is needed
so the primary goal of this computer
layer is essentially interactive
analytics and you need a very very high
level
elasticity in this layer you can you may
need on-demand compute that goes in in
multiple terabytes one day you could
need a few gigabytes of the other day so
you want to be able to scale up and
scale down on demand and depending upon
the cost needs you may also want to
reserve some kind of compute capacity if
you know that and if there that you
never go below this this compute need
but more than that you would not you not
want to be in a situation where your
users don't have enough compute to do
their day-to-day functions if you go and
take this design principles and apply it
in a public cloud environment like
Google cloud you will see very similar
similar components can be built using
the using the tools available for their
on the collection layers you could
either have your your partner storage or
your own internal storage or file system
from where you will ship the data to
Google Cloud you may have a streaming
environment where you're piping in data
either in your own queueing system or
these are your IOT devices or other
devices that are generating this data
and push this data through into the
Google cloud environment using one of
the available choices you could directly
stream this data or you could use
something like up sub for stream and
pub/sub you it's a shortened storage
you're not going to store data here for
years or months that that you would
typically store in a on a desk or a
storage or storage layer you'll be
storing it here for few hours or few
weeks depending upon how delayed
processing you expecting a streaming
pipeline on the backs layer you'd be
using tried-and-tested storage
environment Google Cloud Storage would
offer you a pretty good redundancy this
could be as reliable as you could get in
terms of availability and you could use
this as your primary storage layer to
bring in all your data on top of that if
you want to do your processing you use a
combination of data flow and composer
data flow is as you would know it's an
implementation of Apache beam
and it allows you to very gracefully
integrate streaming pipeline as well as
batch pipeline and bring the data
together and use a single code to
process the data in both both the
environments from both ecosystem you may
also use spanner into the mix we have we
used it pretty extensively found it
pretty useful to do very quick response
time and some milliseconds or hundreds
of millisecond response time key value
lookup on a very large scale dimension
or attribute lookup enemy and usually in
any radix environment you will have some
dimension which has very large volume of
data and you need those attributes to be
looked up in real time as your data is
being processed to make it more
meaningful sparrow is plays a very great
role there and it's a fantastic
transactional database which can have a
massive scale of data and you may want
to use it when you are doing your stream
processing as you move on you read this
data from from store layer using the
processing environment and put it into
an audix database like bigquery which
supports all the typical characteristics
of large scale and it is square in
database that we talked about it has all
under storage and it has encrypted at
rest now you would you be able to take
advantage of columnar compression the
data is laid out you know in highly
optimal fashion and continuously keeps
optimizing itself on its own without you
having to do anything and once you have
your data store in here you could use
the query slots to query this data you
would be using looker as a bi tool for
wearing your to query your data you
could use other tools as well our
preference has been has been looker it's
one great for us and you could also
bring in a Google sheet or other
environment that makes to analyze your
data but essentially in the key aspect
here is the Elastic Compute stores that
you need and the kind of ad hoc analysis
capability you will get using the BI to
like looker as we move on the
architecture that we start
with was quite different we were pretty
much on pram and with the album's
background with her hoop and the kind of
contributions it has made to her - it
was pretty easy for us to spend a blasty
lustre to handle huge volumes of data
the collection layer the collector layer
for us was essentially a set of beacon
service that would that would instrument
the activities that were happening on
different pages capture the signals that
we would need for various use cases and
funnel it to into our private problem
one the storage for real-time was Kafka
and we would use it for temporary
storage until the data is consumed by
downstream pipeline you use Tom's war
and the batch layer would take this data
and put it in the Hadoop environment in
HDFS storage this determined then we
further processed using again the Hadoop
environment and storm which was
essentially you know sister environment
for in our case both clusters were
managed using yeah which again is a
resource scheduler that would you have
typically identified with Thoreau and we
would use that compute to do all kind of
processing you need our underlying data
set and bring it into our database layer
we use two databases on on-prem for
streaming we use to it which was pretty
good at investing last game data and
making it available to the very short
span of time
within seconds for our ready to do stuff
to do for the bachelor for historical
analysis we used high one tails with our
say storage which again is a polymer
storage built for or design for
aeronautics and we made this available
via a bi layer at that point in time
which was stable and the reason for
choosing Cape who was primarily driven
by the limitations that we had with high
on interactive response we knew that
high on tase would perform better for
queries but still could not give
subsequent response time it was not
meant or design
that purpose so you plugged in that hole
using tables data engine which would
allow us to extract the significant
volume of data and cache it into the a
layer and make it available for one uses
some table to do ad hoc analysis and
dashboard for interactive analytics or
for ad hoc analysis without pre-baked
dashboards or pre-built cubes we hooked
the blue curve on top of time and made
it available for users to do at our
campuses we had a custom web application
layer as well which was squaring through
it and which would be used for content
download eggs already too erotic spy
over at Jonestown we handed this data to
our users we started monitoring our
performance and how our users respond to
this architecture we soon learned that
most of the queries that were hitting
for ad-hoc analysis wire look we're too
high we're failing out this significant
percentage of them we're feeling either
due to resource constraints or due to an
intubation issue or how the queries been
kicked off and the queries that
completed even those more than half of
them completed in more than two minutes
or three minutes time which is not an
interactive response time that we needed
or wanted you to our users so we we're
on this environment for a few weeks few
months and we soon learned that this is
not going to work out it's not going to
be something that we started exploring
alternatives and around the time we
specifically focused on the query in
computing the inari squaring the rest of
the system was working on one and as we
started exploring we what caught our
attention was a dremel white paper that
was released by Google just down just a
little while before we were doing this
analysis the focus of Dremel was
essentially to work around the
limitations of MapReduce in terms of
interactive response time when MapReduce
was built to do large-scale patched also
thing drama was built to bridge the gap
still have the goodness of processing
tasks in data
but reduce the response time that a user
would get to treat their data what also
caught our attention was some of the
statistics in the white paper if you
look at it there are tables that were
used with pretty large scale volume we
had one trillion Phyllis row table which
is very similar to the environments we
had internally we have tables with 1200
plus columns which is again something
that we had and we operated on the next
thing that that caught our attention was
the scalability and interactivity if you
can see the interactivity most of the
very seem that were tested out seem to
be completed within 10 seconds now
that's within the ballpark of what we
were looking for in terms of
interactivity hours get a scale and on
the scalability part you can see that
you know this fairly linearly scalable
as you add more nodes you'll be able to
increase your performance and
interactivity of it well we also came
across a pretty nice analysis done by
another third-party company xq which did
analysis and made it available to the
public to see all the options that are
available for large-scale data analysis
and see the concurrency response time of
different solutions as you can see most
of this alternate solutions had major
issues when concurrency went up beyond a
certain threshold the degradation of
query performance was not proportional
to the number of queries being submitted
after that point it was an unusually
slow beyond a certain point which is
something that we observed in our
environment as well and it was it was
reflective of the limitations of what we
are facing in a MapReduce environment
that we had in-house for bigquery
however you can see that the concurrency
response time seemed to be pretty flat
as more Paris came him even though there
was a query deterioration it was pretty
graceful pretty proportional
not drastic as you would see in some of
the other databases so we decided to
give it a shot we relook at our
architecture we obviously did not need
the computer layer that we had
for querying and we wanted to replace it
with with Google flower we also wanted
to relook our we look at our da
architecture or the VI tune that we will
use it as part of this architecture plan
that we have but one of the first thing
that we had to look at as we are moving
massive scale data between our data
centers to Google Cloud was to see what
are the bandwidth limitations that we
have working with our networking team we
realize that the 10 gigabits network
capacity that we had me not suffice for
our names as we you know put in some
more numbers we learned that on an
average whatever we need should be okay
with one with the bandwidth we have but
this would you know pretty much take
away most of the capacity that we had in
the center bandwidth so keeping in mind
other workloads from the company that
maybe eat something like this we decided
to upgrade the bandwidth we also learned
that you know our overall
peak requirement would be somewhere
around 70 bit of it so should we go
ahead and straight away to 70 or more
than that or should be staggered so we
decided to stagger it and monitor the
performance as we go forward and see the
utilization and based on that if there
is a need we go ahead so work with the
Google team gesture-based a direct
bearing connection between the two data
centers and predict the bandwidth to 30
gigabytes capacity that we brought in
very into the mix and cool thing about
bigquery is the is the network that's
one of the first thing that we notice
that and the compute and the storage
communicated with each other with a
combined network bandwidth capacity of
their implementation of Jupiter network
which plays a big role in how the how
the platform performs and the kind of
response time we are able to get even at
such a large scale we moved our data in
there as we started to we're in this
state I realized that we would be able
to now our [ __ ] artists layer and make
it's the primary source for Xavier or
analysis but - voting geeks as well
look it was a tool of preference for us
for multiple reasons but few key aspects
that appeal to us where it's
semantically and stability to handle a
lot of housing needs like aggregate
whereas dynamic building of derive
tables which are essentially what we
call a skew in traditional environment
and you would you'd be able to you know
even persist them within the same data
pretty cool features that we had but one
of the most appealing thing that we
liked about what was the semantic layer
as any of you who has operated warehouse
at scale you know that document in your
data warehouse at such a massive scale
where you have thousands of columns is
it's a big challenge it's not easy to
keep the document up-to-date all the
time now if you come across a tool that
lets you define something like a look at
always local does and allows you to
define your metrics and dimension in the
same place and use the same definition
to generate the data dictionary I think
there's that there's a perfect
documentation that anybody would need
for one and with lucre we were able to
get that what also helps is that when
you have such large skew attributes and
metrics combinations you end up creating
various combination of aggregates in a
typical vi2 for every table that you
create you are going to redefine or we
implement the definitions that you had
to those attributes and metrics and
there's hardly any scope to reuse a
definition every time there is a change
you end up changing multiple files and
data sources in order to bring
consistency usually you're not able to
and you end up creating inconsistent
definition or dictionary for which ends
up creating a lot of confusion
so with looker we we were able to get a
living data dictionary whenever a
definition changes we are also able to
reuse these definitions and we don't
have we do not have to define same
attribute again for a different
aggregate you could simply reuse the
same direction
we also leverage this semantically here
now using Lucas restful api and make
those definitions available to our web
application layer we did not have to
define its own complex API layer with
all the business logic contain all the
business logic stayed in the unified
semantic layer within look at and was
reused by the pair application layer as
well all the tools that were accessing
the data directly using API or Maya the
Luca we also brought in Google sheets
into the mix and Google console was
obviously there and Google sheet proved
to be a super hit within our analyst
community it could be very similar to in
most places and we you know Google sheet
is a pretty commonly used and pretty
popular to that most of the analysts
like to use to communicate that
detestable and with an ability to embed
the sequel within the sheet and be able
to refresh the sheet on the bar this is
pretty powerful feature and something
that we saw in use as we as we rolled it
out we saw it was probably the most
widely used interface after looker by
all over using something that that
everybody has liked not the other way
integration of Google sheet can be query
which we call us which I call is a more
transactional integration where you are
able to enter new new rows within the
worksheet unable to query directly
without any query why I look Google
sheet itself again you'll be able to do
that which saves a lot of time in doing
with prototypes or you know having at
least dimension logic or anything that
you want to make available on demand for
your users wire where we are layer you
should be able to do it using a Google
sheet instead of having to bring in a
database and build build a custom web
application to handle transactional
processing we started monitoring our
usage and we saw that the users were
pretty soon very more than exabyte of
data for month and when you looked at
the performance it seemed like most of
the
succeeding and the ones that were
succeeding bulk of them completed in a
very good interactive response time all
of them went 10 seconds we saw that you
know 30 seconds was the typical response
time that people would get for complex
queries involving large volume which is
pretty acceptable concurrent concurrent
interactive response time that we'd
expect from more uses and it's like to
set up very happy user base now as we
started looking at you know rolling in
the rolling this out and started
investing more and more as capacity on
the environment we also had questions
around the cost of ownership or the
total cost that we are putting into this
and why and cost is not the same for
everybody if you talk to an IT team the
understanding of cost will be very
different from what the business team to
me so we decided to come up with a
currency where you'll be able to put
into all our values to the kind of
benefits you get when you have highly
capable analyst wearing layer available
to your users so picked up some query
pattern this is an example query that
you see and you can see the difference
in the query response time between our
earlier environment between what we see
with the query today if you translate it
to the millions of queries that were
being executed on that environment
that's tens of millions of dollars saved
in just productivity improvement in
order to work on the limitations of
interactivity you would either hire more
people
or you'd you'll have to live with
productivity loss that your that your
hat that your analysts or that your data
users are going to suffer I'm going to
start looking at it and you go and take
a look at your IT team their response
time would usually even though they
would say that you know it's usually the
cheaper hardware which obviously is the
lower cost of ownership their business
would go and share this numbers with
them and give a complete picture and
that essentially use a common currency
that both the teams and organization
could talk to and explain the cost of
for for rolling out such an environment
is this is this is a pretty common
discussion that you would see most of
the time when you bring in or chain
migrate from on trend to 112 and as we
brought in and documented all this
various queries and the response time
and what people are able to do with the
availability of this environment it
settles a lot of this conversations
around the cost of rolling of this
feature the usage numbers went up
dramatically we you know as we've said
this multiple times we see in a peak of
six exabyte queries across month billion
queries are the norm we also seen where
is going as high as 20 million plus as
more and more system queries that
brought in and different events and
different phases in the enterprise with
different demands on the instead of said
we've seen a pretty large volume of data
going on we have you know about 2,000
users using this on a daily basis this
is increasing every we a month and more
and more users being on board it and
we've been able to handle the new use
cases and users free effectively without
much of a change so to summarize what
has made big queries so popular and what
has allowed us to have such a wide
adoption if you have to call out certain
features which we really like and which
we believe has played a huge role on how
this has been about pinon has worked
over the past many years the biggest
thing we as an anything team have gained
out of this as we know more focus on
infrastructure bigquery has been pretty
much no op for us it's somewhat less
itself tuning we don't spend as much
time on sizing of the cluster sizing up
the database defining indexes or trying
to tune the queries that users are
firing if you look at the isolations
between compute and storage also extends
between compute of that is used in
loading the data and compute that is
used in querying the data which makes a
huge difference on how we are able to
manage and commit to or SLA who our
users contain availability and how we
are able to manage our SLA in terms of
user response time to queries
at high concurrency or the whites and
concurrency again it's just a fact of
how it is being architected or how the
isolation works we have not been able to
see any kind of issues with high
concurrent where it is spawns time for
our users the degradation is usually you
know graceful most of the queries will
have slight degradation most of times
users won't even notice it we haven't
had a scenario where runaway query has
been able to you know bring the cluster
almost almost to its knees we haven't
seen that we have seen that before a lot
of you might be facing it in different
environments that you are using the
query has been interactive even at such
a high usage and it's been it's been
working pretty pretty well even when the
users are very months worth of data or
many many months or even in some cases
years worth of data they've been able to
manage that pretty effectively security
has been a key aspect something that we
focus on a lot since we are there's a
lot of data that's that's there we don't
want this to be to be misused or used we
make very very heavy use of Google's
column level security the data is
encrypted of course so you know that
obviously helps but we do use custom
rules column level security and row
level security you set a pretty
extensive monitoring of all data set
Google provides a pretty good and easy
way to set up your DTS or which is data
transfer service that allows you to
monitor all your actions and make it
available for your users and for
yourselves to go and query so you can oh
and pump in this data in bigquery and
very dashboards and reports on top of it
and depending upon what you want to
monitor you can just expose it to
different set of business DMLs have been
a lifesaver for us
and you know this is typical for DML for
data warehousing environment where you
may want to restate the data for various
reasons in absence of efficient DML you
end up reprocessing the entire date down
which is not a good usage of your
compute K pass
if you have a good DML whether it's a
mud statement on it most of the time
we'll be able to very quickly restate
the data without having to go and
reprocess your entire data and run your
entire geology a two way google sheeting
degradation has been big deal I talked
about how our analyst community has used
Google sheet integration very pretty
effectively on the editing side we have
used Google suite integration the other
way around where we insert data into
Google sheet whenever there is a change
in label for example of an attribute or
if you want to bring in some small
lookup dimension that the users want to
query using looker we just create a
sheet we hook it up to bigquery external
table and make it ever before users
compare this to traditional environment
where you would need a separate database
a UI layer to insert those data an ETL
layer to then bring it back to analytics
database in this case bigquery and then
make it available via all those
intermediate steps could be easily
eliminated by simple external table onto
version which for me has been a big you
know big
usage from the T spanner is another tool
that we use pretty extensively on our
streaming pipeline spanner can have a
pretty large kavita the way to see it is
like sequel on BigTable or HBase if
you're familiar with it and it allows
you to do a quick lookup on very large
scale data we have dimensions with
billions of rows and you know streaming
processing would need those attributes
to be looked up to annotate our events
with those attributes and span allows us
to do that
BQ ml has been another great addition to
various offerings just a few years ago
this is something I'm thinking about
you cannot imagine doing machine
learning or it was so hard it's just
also a simple sequel interface
query allows us to do that our users
have been using it to do a pretty
sophisticated honest from within their
windows within the Google sheet
and are able to predict and classify a
lot of things without involving any data
engineer or data scientist they were
able to do it completely on the fly from
something or which they would have to
write a lot of code earlier they can
handle using sequel within the same and
while all these features have had this
pretty extensively and things that have
allowed us to build pretty last internet
scale data warehouse with 100 plus
petabyte of data and the usage status
with you seen and it's it's been it's
been working well and and the
capabilities that we've seen here there
are many more that I will talk about but
these are the key steps that come to my
mind it's been it's been a great
experience for us so far and because it
was really fun to share our learnings
and what we have what you learn using
bigquery and how for experience has been
over the past four or five years using
bigquery and you know hopefully this
helps some of you to to take take some
of the service learnings or some of the
good practices that you learned here and
apply it in your own environment and and
maybe exchange notes on what you have
learnt and you know if there is anything
that you would like to know more about
thank you